am i too old for this i'm shaquita and
i'm 30 years old
learning how to skateboard
skateboarding is something that i've
always wanted to learn how to do it's
always been on my bucket list since i
was a child
i couldn't really learn because i lived
in a very rural area with
not very many concrete roads to practice
on
not only that there just wasn't a lot of
representation for black and brown girls
so that kind of discouraged me as well
but i figured you know what effort you
only live once it's time to learn
because i want to learn how to do the
ollie
an ollie is done by using your back foot
to snap the tail of the board to the
ground
so that the board goes almost vertically
in the air
right as the tail hits the ground you're
sliding your front foot against the
board
to level it out
i've made myself a list of three things
that i need to be able to do
to make me feel like i have mastered the
ollie
number one all four wheels have to leave
the ground
number two i have to be able to do this
on concrete
without my skater trainers number three
to be able to do the ollie while moving
and the cherry on top would be to jump
over something
very unintimidating i studied a few
videos that made me feel confident
enough to go outside and try it
i tried as hard as i could for two days
but something just wasn't clicking
then this complete stranger came up to
us and started showing off
[Applause]
this is when i knew i needed to phone a
friend so i reached out to latasha stone
you are the first black woman to own a
skateboarding brand how do you feel
about that feels
weird like didn't really think about
being the first
until like past couple months here and
like people really pointed that out it's
a great thing it feels awesome
i've been watching betty when i was
looking you up it was saying that your
boards were featured in
an episode or two it was like in the
beginning a couple episodes
that came out i was just like watching
like every single like deck like was
that one mine like trying to try to
spot it i'm definitely interested in
getting one of your boards but my thing
is i don't want to mess it up
i hear that from so many people they're
like it's so pretty i don't want to
write it
just just message me which one you want
and i'll just like send you one oh
thank you i wasn't expecting that do you
have
completes coming out in like two months
and i have this really cute collab
coming up with
black girls anime that's exciting okay
so i'm trying to learn the ollie for
this video do you think that's too
ambitious
no ollie is the base of every trick
you're going to learn that's definitely
one thing that
you should work on getting down first
i'll send you the video of me doing this
already and maybe you can critique me
on what i'm doing wrong you know what my
friend leticia is in l.a maybe you can
meet up with her and
she can like show you how to do it
better now that would be so much easier
yeah that'll be perfect you got this
thank you
i took latasha's advice and i reached
out to latisha
and she got back to me my name's leticia
nicole i've been skating for about 10
years
you could start off by showing me what
you have and then go from there
super good it's awesome you started off
with like your
your back foot a little off of the tail
i personally
think that you'll get a better pop if
you put your foot more on the tail
and your goal should be that when you
pop
[Music]
you want to try and land on your bolt
there's so much to think about all at
once
perfect in your head say the steps it's
all about like
muscle memory you already know you need
to step on that you bend your knees
so don't say that you're working right
now on remembering to pop
then say pop and then jump on the bolt
then your body will
get used to doing those and you won't
have to say the mechanics you'll just
automatically kind of start doing it
pop slide jump on the boat yeah
use your toes your board's not coming
with you so that's what you're going to
do is you're going to use your
your tippy toes
i don't know why it's messing me up now
why main thing is really getting that
tail to touch the ground
oh okay cool that was perfect okay i
think we might have unlocked something
right now you're kind of just doing this
yeah but what about that like finesse
cuz that finesse in it with your ankle
nice that was scarier but it felt right
tippy toes knees up bolts
yeah so the board's leaving the ground
now the border's leaving the ground now
perfect
all of a sudden i'm scared it's like now
that the board is actually doing
now my mind is like
yeah wiggle it uh
perfect so good
good
[Music]
why is my board flipping all of a sudden
ah i think i need to do something else
for a while
[Music]
is enough speed
i just want to take a few minutes to
actually chat with you and learn more
about your experience in skateboarding
i wasn't really allowed to skate until i
was out of the house and all that so i
was like 17 years old
bought my own skateboard and started
doing what i wanted to do
there wasn't like very many women in
skateboarding
at all much less women of color i've
always been like super attracted to
skateboarding i thought it looks like
magic to me how can you make something
that's under your feet move without
touching it yeah it's magic
all right i'm ready i guess we had
enough of a break right i feel
revived now it's time to cross off
number two on my list
but first i'm going to put these skater
trainers on because i'm scared
and i'm going to slowly remove them as i
get used to working on the concrete
oh dope
oh feeling kind of brave
medic on standby
oh that was good no real move that is
different
yo that was pretty good take one off
take one off
take the last one off
oh lord here it is
i don't think i'm not even gonna think
that anything changed you know
except that i just rolled
oh i'm rolling before i'm even ready
i got scared
got it
i think we did a lot today yeah we've
come far come a long way
oh man i don't think we've got this with
just the internet
and videos so thank you probably not
i'm 30 doing this so i feel like i'm
starting real late in the game
i'm 33. i don't feel like there's ever
like an age that's too late
there's ladies that start and they're
like 50. they have cancer
and this is their thing that they're
gonna put all their energy into
that takes their mind off of all their
stress and their problems
a few skate clinics where like people
from like the community can't like come
and like learn how to skate and i was
like one lady that was like 57
that showed up like she learned how to
like roll and like go down the ramp and
stuff
like it was dope skating has no age you
can skate
you can skate forever my dad literally
asked me if i was having a midlife
crisis
so um today is my first day outside
practicing since my lesson with tish
and i'm gonna go for it
[Music]
i really wanted to get the ollie nice
and locked in so i kept practicing and
practicing until i felt like i can jump
over something
something nice and small and not
[Music]
intimidating
[Music]
i didn't hit it i went all the way over
yes what
[Music]
when i was younger not seeing people who
look like me do this was a big
factor in me not being interested
anymore it is really
cool to be part of a community of women
who skate and who uplift each other
it's so pretty thank you latasha
this is awesome this is where it's gonna
go
it's kind of perfect actually
you